you're a Dodgers fan but here's the
weird thing
I don't know how people know this
nationally but yeah you cannot watch the
Dodgers on TV in Los Angeles yeah I'm
about to kick somebody asked me yeah
let's talk about that this is a
controversy with DIRECTV they will not
make a deal with the Dodgers they don't
seem to be able to do what you do is it
I don't think it's with the Dodgers I
think it's DIRECTV
and his Time Warner yeah cable they
gotta get it together baby what's
happening yo y'all business man you're
losing a generation yeah here saying
that you saying that they're they're
killing themselves they're they're
they're hurting the game they're gonna
these are they're driving sports fans
where there are young kids that could be
watching baseball right now I'm just
gonna lose them yeah they about to be on
the iPads they're gonna be on a stupid
phones whatever they're gonna be on you
know I'm saying they gonna be doing
everything but watching the Dodgers in
you guys haggling over a couple of
dollars here and there you gonna lose a
generation of fans you know my son is
already mad and I'm trying to say man
stick with it stick with it they're
gonna come back get it together we want
to see some Dodgers in LA
[Applause]
you